[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're probably hours maybe days away
from your fantasy drafts the important
preseason stuff that's over it wasn't
too bad other than a major retirement
and an unfortunate ACL injury and if
you're getting ready for those Japs just
think back to last year think of taking
lady on bail in the first round and then
he had to apologize for you taking him
in the first round that did not win you
a fantasy championship but that's what
I'm here to do we're gonna win you won
we're gonna start that right now it's
your fantasy fire drill sportsbook and
it's time for your fantasy fire drill I
am at camp and we are getting you ready
for your dress we're getting that roster
construction put together ahead of week
number one and we are most importantly
taking your questions I'll talk sleepers
I'll talk bus and anything that's gone
on in the world of the NFL maybe even
your life I'm here to help you with drop
those questions drop your comments in
there we'll get to them throughout the
show as soon as I'm done I'm jumping
into the app I'm getting your questions
there as well and we'll be with you
every Sunday this is a Thursday I'm
aware but every Sunday we'll be with you
getting you ready for week 1 with the
latest information but now it's it's
time for your question throughout the
show let's get these questions in right
now from Mike sharp I thought I know
Mike start from somewhere no luck in
Indy yeah I know how much does this hurt
Hilton and Marlon maxi why Hilton was
right around my top 10 he's now down to
about wide-receiver 18 or 19 I still
have faith in Jacoby reset much
different team than two years ago Marlon
Mac I probably wasn't as high on as many
in the industry before the lock
retirement so I didn't drop him down as
much I am concerned about his scoring
potential without luck and Andy big blow
to the NFL and fantasy rosters a be sold
helmet thoughts on Duke Johnson I have
him as my Flex good value for the 10th
round if you're getting Duke Johnson to
the 10th round I don't know what league
you're in maybe you kept them there
that's awesome I have seen them go as
high as the fourth round in PPR formats
I would say to speak careful he's never
had more than 105 carries in a season he
did that as a rookie and that was years
ago I would tell you to be careful that
when final cuts come down maybe the
Houston Texans look around for another
bigger back to help take some of the
workload off Duke Johnson's plates
t-yong 260 Le'Veon or obj simply I like
the volume I like the ceiling of obj on
a better team more than Odell Beckham
we'll talk more about good versus bad
teams later on in the show
flooding puddle is it worth touching
Melvin Gordon be careful how you phrase
that I would say this think about the
third round I don't know if we'll see
him in the first couple weeks of the
season I think we will see him probably
week three or week four so I would say
he's a third-round pick I'm not taking
him in the first round I'm more fake
than Zeke shows up to open the season
Jade SEO will Jacoby Brissette reach
number one QB status or QB one status at
all during the season as I said earlier
I have faith in the Colts with de
coimbra set at the helm this is not two
years ago when he just got traded to the
team and had to start right away this is
a much better offense with Blair's
better players around a better coaching
I'm not telling you is gonna be in your
lineup right away but I think he will be
worth using as a streamer especially
because he's got the legs that'll give
you some bonus yardage Graz Dillo who
would rather have on the bench Damien
Harris or Ronald Jones I'll say Damien
Harris I know Sony Michele is the guy
that got James White there but he's a
third-round pick on a much better team
I'm still not a believer in Ronald Jones
it's still Payton Barbour show on the
pass happy Tampa Bay Buccaneers now
those questions I read apparently we
have video questions as well I'll take
some co-hosts let's go to the video
board for our first question hey Matt
are there any backup quarterbacks I
should think about drafting or at least
keeping an eye on not drafting but
keeping an eye on is the key there last
year Josh Allen was not a starting
quarterback played well in the fantasy
playoffs Lamar Jackson we're gonna talk
about shortly was not the starting
quarterback of the Ravens he mattered so
yes I would keep an eye on someone like
maybe Daniel Jones the Giants would be
foolish not to go to him sooner rather
than later
they're not a very good team the volume
should be there for him to pass and I
don't think the weapons around him are
too bad either so yes keep an open mind
fantasy versus reality is a different
commerce
and one we're gonna start to have right
now as we move into these sleepers the
sleepers the guys that maybe you can get
later on we're gonna boost you to a
fantasy championship in some cases maybe
it's about patience maybe they don't
come through it all right away or maybe
they do stur right away so let's talk
about the quarterbacks here's the
faceoff here we're gonna talk about
those that are big sleepers by the
consensus verses where I met Lamar
Jackson you're number two Mitch to
Biscay you're number three let's take a
look at these numbers where I have these
guys for the season Lamar Jackson a
divisive player I think in the fantasy
world he's saying he's gonna throw the
ball about 30 times a game by the way
that's not a big number but would be way
up from last season the passing yards I
can't go crazy about I think he will be
the number one quarterback rusher that's
always a bonus do I trust him as a
weekly starting quarterback that answer
is no it's not just about him the
receiving corps is not that good they
also have a very good defense so he may
not have to throw the ball that much
he's a fine second quarterback in your
to QB leagues but he's more of a backup
to me in your one quarterback leagues a
player I do like that I get it maybe
he's not all that good but last year
when Mitch Tripp Biscay was on the field
he played at a top-ten level and you
might be surprised to hear that once
again he runs that's a big bonus you
don't get that with rivers or Ben or
Brady or Brees you don't get that you
get that for Mitch that's hidden value
there doesn't make him a better
quarterback in reality but in fantasy
it gives him a boost he's in a better
offense with good weapons Matt Nagy has
made Mitch do Biscay a better
quarterback in reality versus fantasy
sometimes you have to weigh those that
way those way those things even when I
said sometimes my fantasy advice isn't
the best Mitch true Biscay in reality
maybe not that great in fantasy he'll
come through
that's the quarterback that's the
sleepers I like at the quarterback
position the running back position Oh
two of the biggest names right now two
of the biggest rookies out there right
now Damon Montgomery in Chicago yes
we'll stay there and Myles Sanders with
the Philadelphia Eagles I love the
talent of both of these players but
opportunity I think is what's the
separation here between the two David
Montgomery
cago I do think is an upgrade over
Jordan Howard but you still love to read
: there they brought in Mike Davis
Taylor Gabriel Alan Robertson Trey
Burton Anthony Miller they have a lot of
weapons there it's good for mr. Biscay I
think it could be annoying at times for
David Montgomery especially where he's
going his ATP has them sometimes into
the third round I think he's going a
little bit too high I think he'll
frustrate you just because they have a
lot of options in Chicago and as we saw
last season they had no problem
spreading the ball around now Myles
Sanders I'm a little bit higher on than
Montgomery just facing the fact that you
can get him around maybe two later and I
know what Doug Peterson has done he has
driven us nuts with the running backs
they like five different guys last year
as a running back have the most points
in a game for the team didn't mean very
much but they used all those guys why
because they didn't have a real good one
that is a real good one Myles Sanders is
a heck of a player we didn't see a ton
of a Penn State because he had that guy
say Kwan Barkley in front of them I
think we haven't seen the best of mile
Sanders but we'll see that right away in
Philadelphia I'm not asking for 200
carries give me that LeGarrette Blount
roll from a couple years ago 180 caries
plus the catches maybe the best old line
in the league on a great team
I think Myles Sanders you take as an RB
three who can win you a fantasy
championship so we did quarterbacks we
did running backs now we talked
receivers and to me this is a no-brainer
I know people are on Christian McCaffrey
let's give me Christian Kirk we like
McCaffrey we know love I like Tron a
while sit so here's where I'm at with
Christian Kirk I like click Kliff
Kingsbury I like that the office is
going to throw the ball a bunch I'm not
totally sold on this big-time talent of
Christian Kirk I think they have a lot
of intriguing talent but nobody that
stand out and that includes him and I've
seen Kirk go in the sixth round
I don't see the real breakout potential
for him I do see it in Geronimo Allison
in Toronto Allison if you followed me
last year was a sleeper candidate and
for the first four weeks of the season
scored more than 15 fantasy points per
game he was coming through multiple
injuries he had the cord injury he had
the concussion we didn't see him he's in
the slot receiver this year for Aaron
Rodgers Aaron Rodgers loves throwing to
the slot that's his place to go oh there
we go and there's a mismatch
here with him because he's a big slop
receiver small nickel corners he's gonna
do some damage there and here's the
other thing he knows right he knows too
many people that I'm gonna be really
good this season cuz then they'll know
and they'll take them
I have Aaron Rodgers as QB three that
means not only do I believe in Davante
Adams but I believe in Toronto Alison
heck I believe in NBS as well it's a
bounce-back season for the Packer
offense at Geronimo Alison will be a big
part of that yes the piano the now
iconic piano means it's time for a matte
moment one player I separated from this
group one player I love is Tevin Coleman
you know who loves Tevin Coleman more
Kyle Shanahan Kyle Shanahan said we're
gonna give this guy a big-money contract
even though we have Jerick McKinnon Jeff
Wilson Matt Brito Raheem moster we have
all these guys we did well but he loves
Tevin Coleman he made Tevin Coleman a
top 20 running back even with Devonta
Freeman there in Atlanta I heard this
here's some inside info when Tevin
Coleman was in Atlanta and Kyle Shanahan
left for San Francisco Kyle Shanahan
still had Tevin Coleman over for
Thanksgiving dinner last year moved his
dad Mike aside you get the head of the
table this year he was recruiting them
we said hey you can move in right next
to me I got a guest house well we'll
just give you ten million dollars you
can live with me that's how much Kyle
Shanahan loves Tevin Coleman and Tevin
Coleman unlike in Atlanta with Kyle
Shanahan is on top of the depth chart
with the 49ers Kyle Shanahan no Shanta
Hannigan's there go get Tevin Coleman
and as you'll see in my article tomorrow
I think he'll be a top 20 running back
this season the moments over but now
more of your questions are coming fire
them into the comments section john-boy
12 who would you take is the first pick
at an 18 draft I would take say Kwan
Barclay I will tell you this about an 18
draft you can push that quarterback
position way down the line you don't
need it till much later on
you only need eight of them and your
starting lineup anyway for those 18
moving on here 8:27 thoughts on Tyler
boy very solid player no AJ Green
actually might hurt him a little bit I
actually talked to Tyler Boyd about this
last year he said
benefit from defense's having to pay
attention to AJ Green Green could be out
three four maybe five weeks so Boyd is
just kind of an okay wide receiver - I'm
not excited for him to be on my team
I'll take them I also don't love Andy
Dahlen sorry I know ginger nation we
move on here mudbone 1999
if Josh Jacobs falters another rookie
running back do you think the Raiders
will give jail and Rashard a chance to
be a three down back no he had those
chances last year when Marshawn Lynch
was gone
Doug Barton was just okay I know Martin
just got cut loose Jalen shards a
changeup back he's a past catcher I
think Josh Jacob gets every chance in
the world to be the man and open and I
think he will be that man knocked er
through with me or something
KB 1225 if Wolfe fuller stays healthy
for 14 out of 16 games if where do you
think he ranks in PPR I think he's gonna
be in the top 30
I haven't write about there now but man
that has been a problem for will fuller
staying on the field but when he's there
I feel like you expect him to score a 40
or 50 yard touchdown every week because
he connects with the Shaun Watson and of
course everybody's worried about the
andre hopkins he can be top 30 but that
it is a big in fill up 65 78 says with
Bruce Arians as head coach well Jameis
Winston averaged 20 fantasy points per
game I don't think he'll average that I
think there'll be weeks a reason top
five quarterback and they'll be weeks
where he's number 25 that's just what
Jameis is I don't think that's going to
change at this point in his career there
is going to be volume there where he
goes to 375 and three touchdowns and
there's gonna be games where he goes for
185 and four picks that's the nature of
Jameis Winston but unlike last year you
don't have to worry about fitzpatrick
taking his job that's a challenge flag I
am now used to these and once again
we're in Vegas we don't have to go to
New York a challenge and I'm told this
is a video challenge so let's find out
what the challenge is all about a Matt
this is Brandon from Vegas and
apparently you think handcuffs are out
of sorts well I'm here to tell you that
my three championships from last year
say otherwise I mean what do you tell
them you're not gonna pick up Darius
guys if you got Adrian Peterson in your
backfield or general Henderson's not
gonna save you when Gurley blows his
knee come on man I've been running
handcuffs and Zac Stacy
so I'm challenging you this is official
this is me I'm all in on handcuffs all
in on handcuffs yet those championships
he mentioned didn't mention any the
handcuffs from last season clearly
wearing a Redskins jersey mentioned two
Redskins so maybe he's playing fantasy
here instead of here and Zac Stacy's
like five years ago if you're gonna go
get a handcuff you better be damn sure
you know with that handcuff is you think
it's Tony Paula in Dallas okay but
here's what I want from a handcuff if
I'm handcuffing a top five a top ten
back I want at least the top 20 back in
terms of replacement value now in some
cases and you might think it's clear but
if you're taking down and cook yeah I
might grab Alexander Madison and my best
ball leagues but it doesn't mean I'm
grabbing them in all my leagues I'm not
taking right quell arms that just
because I have four net because these
are not clear situations and they're
very fluid we're coming to the end of
the preseason there will be cuts but it
doesn't mean these situations these
depth charts are locked in I'm not in on
handcuffs because I think you could do
better elsewhere now we move on that's
what the show is all about black
hey-zeus Zeke Hopkins or DJ if all are
on the board
fifth overall in a PPR League I'll say
this if you're concerned about Zeke if
you're concerned about David Johnson
with Arizona you want to just take
Hopkins go ahead and do so I think he's
got the most up side I would like to
know that he's under contract of the
Dallas Cowboys I think he will be but if
you're drafting in a couple hours you're
drafting tonight you want to just play
it safe it's not a bad thing to play it
safe with DeAndre Hopkins
sumon one how likely is it that Josh
Gordon
Tyler Boyd where Kris out Godwin end up
as wide receiver one it's not gonna be
Gordon I think he's the same players
last year
Boyd's more of a - Chris got was got a
chance we just talked about Bruce Arians
offense you don't have Humphries ending
there there anymore you know the Shawn
Jackson there Bruce Arians will throw up
that much more their defenses and good
so those targets to be had Chris Kyle
ones got to talent an opportunity to
find his way into the wide receiver one
group this season SJ kado - says I got
freezin Brady in the eleventh and
twelfth round
good job waiting these guys can't be
that washed up right no it's not about
being washed up both teams are very good
teams which means they play with the
lead which means they can run the ball
and they both run it quite
well with chimera with latavius Murray
with Sony Michele so maybe they're not
putting up massive numbers I don't think
they're washed up I just think they're
on good teams where they don't have to
be like Ben Roethlisberger thrown the
ball 670 times they're not like the
Bucks we're gonna play behind and throw
it all day
or like calimary in Arizona where their
defense is a joke and we could put 12
people that are watching me right now
out there and probably do a better job
opportunities big volume is big it just
might not be there for Brees and Brady
this year the man 1050 507 picking a PPR
and are you alerted to any cheese's how
did you know Parmesan Romano and blue
cheese and sorry if I give you bed at
fantasy advice please don't put that in
my food the various chefs here at
Caesar's Palace 7th pick probably a wide
receiver spot if you just want to play
it safe Beckham Thomas Adams are gonna
be fine they're chilly fan 132 ninth
picking a 10-person lead should I take
mahomes in the second or the third I
don't want to lose him it's okay don't
feel like you have to get him you got
them in the 11th round last year here's
something you may not know Josh Allen
outscored patchable Holmes and the
fantasy playoffs last year you can find
quarterbacks you take one like mahomes
the second or third round you're gonna
hurt the rest of your team he's really
good but it'll hurt your team elsewhere
hook them 10 best packet number 3 9 PPR
I would love to say that to Z I would
love to say that if you're drafting in
three days ich will be in the Dallas
Cowboys locker room ready to go for week
number one but I can't say that right
now
it's Berkeley its McCaffrey if you just
want to take camara there I have no
problem with it let's just hope Zeek
signs Terry get a deal done Pete grass
101 do I draft the defense late or pick
one up after the draft late is where I
would always say and that's going to
lead me right now into more draft rules
and most importantly now I have
something to point to this is totally
not an antenna from spots III in the
Caesars Palace parking lot I promise you
it's a very important draft pointing
stick I did not steal this even though
I'm from North Jersey and know how to
acquire things my rules we did five last
week we do five more this week and
speaking of defenses I say pick your
defense based on week-one matchup I know
what the graphic said on the BR gridiron
Twitter account Instagram that I had the
Cowboys ranked number one I don't the
Bears are the best
defense for me but I'm not taking the
Bears in the 12th round because I'll go
take players that are diamonds in the
rough that I can use later on it running
back a receiver what I will do is start
streaming from the get-go from week one
like the Cowboys taking on the Giants
they also have the Dolphins they also
have the Redskins on the schedule to
open the season so not only are they
good for week one but you can keep them
around for two more weeks stream your
defenses immediately and take them deep
defenses in the last or second last
round number two don't load up on risk
you're gonna take chances I know that
maybe you take Melvin Gordon in the
third round okay but I don't know if I
put Todd Gurley and it's arthritic knee
on that same team that could be very
dangerous it would be like the Booker's
here at caesars booking Lauryn Hill for
an 8:00 p.m. show and expecting their
show up on time that's a lot of risk to
load up on so pick your spots when it
comes to risk you can have Todd Gurley
on the team but do you really want to
have them on a team that may not have
Melvin Gordon out there for the first
couple weeks risk wisely number three it
seems so simple doesn't it avoid bad
teams I use this as a tiebreaker
there's useful fantasy players on all 32
teams but when you need a tiebreaker
here's what you'd like to avoid anything
to do with Daniel Snyder Washington
Redskins maybe you're between guys and
another running back you feel better
about on a better team a Daryl Henderson
perhaps maybe you take him you don't
want to turn it to this Miami Dolphins
fan and have to rely on Kenyan Drake and
Kaylin balázs and Micha sickie and
whatever that quarterback situation is
gonna be you don't want to do that you
don't want to just avoid taking Jim
selfies then that's totally me I swear
just be careful avoid bad teams avoid
bad decisions that could hurt you in the
end don't connect yourself to any of
these things
number four auxin drafts it's not real
money I mean you'd like to get real
money when it's all said and done but if
you sit there at the end and you go I
got seven bucks remaining you can't go
use that to buy dinner
you can't go use that to go buy a beer
because it doesn't count the difference
with seven bucks left in your $200
auction budget could be Devonta Freeman
versus Christian McCaffrey could be
Robert Woods versus juju Smith Schuster
three or four bucks here there could be
the difference between the tier and then
you realize after the fact why do I
still have this money if it's a buck
okay but don't go for all these values
because if you're saving in the end that
money means absolutely nothing
spend it all and spend it wisely number
five this is personal I think you should
integrate this into your leagues if you
cannot pronounce their name you can't
take them here's my spelling bee it's
not juju shoe Meister
it's juju Smith Schuster yeah somebody
once called them that to me it's not
Christian McCafferty it's Christian
McCaffrey it's not Miles Austin it's not
Austin miles it's Miles Austin pretty
simple I just think it's a B rule if
you're gonna draft fan Roethlisberger
you have to spell it ro e th lis ber ger
I move on to the next round of the
quarterback spelling bee just know how
to spell know the players you're taking
put a little effort in that's all I'm
saying
those are some rules here that again I
think is the piano
it's another mad moment now we talked
about some draft rules we talked about
some sleepers I want to give you someone
who I think has some bust potential now
you may have taken this play already so
don't get too squeamish they mean
Williams looks like the guy in Kansas
City he was the guy at the end of last
season he may have won you a fantasy
championship but last season was the
busiest season of Damian Williams career
50 carries never more than at at any
point this career doesn't have a 30
catch season to his name I know Carlos
Hyde's probably getting caught in the
next couple of days I know that nobody's
had more than like four carries on the
team but they're asking a lot of Damian
Williams at this point in his career
it's not year two he's been in the
league for more than half a decade it's
a little dangerous to be asking so much
of Damian Williams with an ATP right now
that puts him at the end of the second
round
and as our b12 and don't forget maybe
Andy Reid calls up his old buddy LeSean
McCoy in Buffalo for a little insurance
so be careful of the bus potential a
baleen way okay hold on speed around
it's sweaty the lights are on and I need
to keep all the makeup that I'm clearly
wearing out of my face to get your
questions in wack and doodle I have the
first pick in my draft with 12 teams so
I go Barclays and running back wide
receiver with back-to-back picks you got
to know who's gonna be there and we
don't know who's gonna be there I would
say this if you have Barclays I'm not as
inclined to go get that next running
back it could be two receivers maybe
it's George kettle their base Sean do my
enemies stand a chance against me the
season while you're watching the show so
the simple answer is of course they do
not will we have next on the speed round
Finn's 15 the best Dolphins receiver
it's Marc duper Chris Chambers it's not
Devante Parker it's never Devante Parker
did you draft them cut them right now
it's probably Kenny Stills if he doesn't
get traded you don't want any of the
Dolphins receivers on your fantasy team
dad will my wife ever come back dad if
you're sitting amongst the crowd and you
pretty much live in these seats here at
the Caesar sports book she's not coming
back but make sure you take care of the
kids at those winnings red 40 hood
should I start Pollard with Ingram and
lead Howard on the bench
well we're ten days out
from the start of the season you make no
lineup decisions today and maybe we'll
find out that Zeke's playing in week one
and then powered means absolutely
nothing
moving on here d have manual Sanders ADP
put some seven or eight rounded seventh
or eighth round should I take him in
round six I will always say this about
ATP if you like a player enough you
don't have to be tied to ATP it's a guy
when I take Emmanuel Sanders in the
sixth round coming off with torn
Achilles I will not but don't ever be
tied to ADP if you have more questions
keep putting them in the comments
because as soon as I walk off the stage
to wipe all the stuff off of my face I'm
gonna help you guys out for the next
thirty minutes and by the way we're
gonna be with you every Sunday right
here in the sports book at Caesars at
8:30 Pacific 11:30 Eastern every week
every Sunday the latest news injuries
and active my deep sleepers and we'll
get plenty of your questions in keep
hitting them up check out my season
predictions article coming out and don't
worry big board week one deep sleepers
article every single week during the
season and we'll be back here next
Sunday 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific and
I'm Matt camp for your fantasy fire
drill
you
you